the first war for Leonia was a clash of
blue against gold
reason against Faith the Stars against
the old tree
Champions fought on either side but none
were as great as ranala and Radigan
who somehow put their differences aside
from this Union three children were born
each with radigans flaming red hair
reichardt radon and Rani
of the three the princess Rani was most
favored by the mother karia was a
matriarchal society after all and power
would inevitably pass to her
so with ranala leading her by the hand
she found it her very own Moon
butter Moon would be eclipsed by the two
fingers who spoke for the greater will
they schemed to have the young emperion
follow their path a puppet on their
strings
[Music]
foreign
and so they granted her a shadow
a half wolf
named Blythe
given to protect Rani all in the name of
the greater will
but it was a mistake and Rani and Blythe
grew extremely close
so Rani Grew Older with loyal allies by
her side
and thanks to the greater will she was
never alone
unlike her mother who would be abandoned
by radical
[Music]
after this Ronaldo was no champion
she was destroyed by grief and left with
nothing but radicands golden egg
meanwhile Radigan reforged his Moonlight
Greatsword into a great sword of order
[Music]
showing his true colors as he embraced
his other half
the sword was once a gift of betrothal
not anymore
suddenly bereft of her parents Rani
ventured deep into the woods and there
she found a new mentor
a snowy Crone well versed in witchcraft
who taught the young rally in the
absence of her mother
in contrast to Rani radon grew an
admiration of the father
and in an unparalleled Act of power he
mastered gravity magic and turned
against the Stars
[Music]
reichardt on the other hand writhed and
wrinkled against order as did Rani who
would not acquiesce and yet her body
belonged to the golden order
she was a demigod
perhaps even more than she herself knew
so she devised a plot stealing death and
forging it into black blades that could
Cast Away her Imperium flesh
and so as order slowly fell apart she
set aside her great room and left with
Blythe and EG
and was never seen again
oh yes tarnished are we come to the
lands between for the Eldon ring
of course you have no shame in it
unfortunately for you however you are
made in this
[Music]
hey
I have a quest to use is ring it will
summon a spectral Steve
current
Thou Art of passing skill
Warrior blood must truly run in thy
veins tarnish
always a pleasure
care to purchase anything
the howl of a wolf
in the Mist wood
pose he must still be skulking about
I know
why not meet him for yourself next time
you hear the wolves howl
make this signal right under the source
don't fret there is nothing to fear I
just have an inkling the two of you
might hate it off
it's early in the game and you're
desperate for your first Quest
that how has not stopped ever since you
set foot here and it comes from a rare
High Point in the Mist wood one that
peeks over its Treetops here you can
find the half wolf named Blythe it's as
if he's looking for something as if he's
in need of information so you can get
his attention with the same signal that
he and kale must have set up to do trade
Carly sent you did he ever the bloody
busybody hmm
maybe to him you don't seem so strange
the name's Blythe I'm looking for a man
who goes by darrowell he fled somewhere
nearby also I've heard come tell me if
you find him before I do I can offer you
ample reward
is nothing but a traitor and in need of
a fitting end to his tail
darawill is a bloodhound Knight a sect
of Fighters who were trained as hunters
and trackers these beastly Knights never
speak but they choose their own master
and are supposed to be loyal to them for
life even renala had such an oath sworn
beast in her employ and she also had
Blythe who is yet another half-woven
Warrior who is defined by his loyalty
perhaps it's for this reason that Blythe
takes Daryl Will's treachery so
personally
[Music]
hey
darauel rotting in a cell is no true
Justice no
this is where it ends for you
[Music]
oh
my God
[Music]
ah right
there you are how to work for it but
it's done don't say I'm not a man of my
word
your prize
oh yes
I should say if you venture North to
real lucaria and come across a venerable
blacksmith who's a little on the large
side tell him I sent you until we sure
to treat you right I owe you one I
reckon that's enough chit chat for now
this time we parted ways
of course we don't know the
circumstances of Dara Will's traitorous
acts but we do know that Blythe is
obsessed with loyalty and here perhaps
he is projecting his expectations of
loyalty upon another
ah then you met blind did you
[Music]
wonderful
I'm glad I pointed you in his Direction
he's boorish blunt
and couldn't find his nose with both
hands
but he's a good egg
I think the two of you are sure to find
the best in one another
after this word of your exploits begins
to spread and the Church of Ella is
engulfed by a strange sleep mist
[Music]
this way tarnished
may I have a word
a pleasure to meet thee tarnished
and the witch Rena I'd heard tale of a
tarnished hurting about Atop A spectral
Steed and upon looking into the matter
the talk isomies is of thee Thou Art
possessed to the power no to go forth
the spectral Steve named torrent ah
it hoped
I was entrusted this for thee by
tolerance former master
to the Battle of calling forth spirits
summon them with it
Ash and returned to the Earth tree the
spirits will obey thine command but
briefly as they recall battles passed
now it is dying
to do it as thou wishes
forgive my intrusion tarnished I doubt
we shall again meet
but all the same
learn while the lands between
how long will it be I wonder before the
tarnished Tire of a basins to the two
fingers
the two fingers so long ago great
Champions would gather at the round
table and listen to the fingers for they
are envoiced to the greater will and the
greater will is widely regarded as the
ultimate power in the universe so the
two fingers speak with its language of
light but they are far from benevolent
and it was the two fingers that forsook
the tarnished long ago when their Grace
was lost only to welcome them back upon
the shattering of the olden ring now
they are wisened trembling and bent with
age yet still they shepherd members of
the Round Table hold sharing
incantations of light and warmth but
also shadows and silence they have high
hopes for the tarnished that even should
they be wounded even should they fall
that they will continue to fight for
their Duty
but many suspect that the fingers are
corrupted broken
their guidance skewed
for now Grace leads you to Leonia known
for its vast forests and ever-present
Folk
and its North stands The Academy of Raya
lucaria in the East there is a high road
that runs north to south and the western
coast has always been closely associated
with carrion royalty some of whom remain
to this day
this is eg the carrion blacksmith that
Blythe sent you to find
Blythe actually did that
DD quite a rare occurrence for such a
guarded Soul as he perhaps he sensed
something unusual about you at any rate
if you're friendly with Blythe I will
give you whatever guidance I can and
pray for your success
long ago trolls like EG swore an oath to
Queen ranala of karia and were
eventually called into service to fight
in her war against the golden order
eventually carrier and Brian Lucario
would join with the golden order only
for Radigan to abandon rinala and then
leave Leonia in this state of civil
Strife but again that was long ago
Brave tarnished a word of warning if you
please this territory once belonged to
the Korean royal family
their manner lies not far beyond this
point when the real Lucario Academy
turned on the karians the Knights of the
cuckoo descended on this tract after
leveling it They carried on to the manor
the Guardians were taken off guard
but their strengths had not waned and
they repelled the knights Onslaught by
Conjuring an enchanted snare that
remains potent to this day that is why I
say tarnished
Don't Go Near The Manor unless you wish
to lie with the corpses of the heedless
Knights of the Goku
[Music]
thank you
amidst carious enemies and treasure the
Knights of the cuckoo live on as puppets
who are forced now to fight for the
carrians that they once tried so hard to
destroy
perhaps you'd be better off exploring
Raya lucaria the academy that closed its
doors to the world
after the shattering the academy wisely
declared that it wouldn't interfere and
locked its Gates so it is that even now
it's filled with Scholars or at least it
was
these Sorcerers dedicated themselves to
Glenstone research and they venerated
many Masters and their Headmaster was
ranala who was also the queen of carrier
but Ronaldo disgraced herself by Falling
for Radigan who left her witless and
inane so now there is this limited
carrion presence in rayalucaria except
for a few loyalists who defend the grand
Library
4. it is here that ranala remains locked
away with the great Rune of The Unborn
[Music]
friend
hush a little cover
[Music]
I'll soon birthday a new
Sweeting fresh and pure
[Music]
children born Anew by ravala are all
frail and short-lived
and radigan's golden protection can only
last so long
Ronaldo's true defense lies in the
golden egg which is Enchanted with a
snare it's a spell that conjures a
version of ranala at the height of her
power something designed by the daughter
to protect the mother
upon my name is Ronnie the witch
mother's Rich Lumber shall not be
disturbed by thee
foul trespasser
send word far and wide
of the last queen of karya granola of
the full moon
and the Majesty of the night she
conjureth
[Music]
Ane
thank you
in this battle rinala is defended by her
oath bound beasts Giants and dragons
that had partnered with her over her
long age of wondering the lands between
for she was there at the beginning of it
all
[Music]
oh little Ronnie
my dear daughter
weave thy night into being
this was merely a fight against a
conjured spirit and yet those final
words seem real
back at Korea Manor you progressed
towards the three sisters towers that
are defended by a doula who is rani's
oath sworn Dragon a doula was once a
Devourer of sorceress until she was
bested by Rani and subsequently she
swore a nightly oath to her Dark Moon
flees before we can defeat her but we'll
see her again
for now we're granted access to rani's
rise
oh
again we cross paths I believe I said my
name was Rena well last we met it
pleases me to see torrent Hale and
Hearty
tarnished what business has thou here
I have no memory of inconvenient
invitation
no reason in particular though claimest
intriguing
than mayhaps fate hath steered thee to
this reunion
World thou enter into my service I am
the witch Ronnie I stole death long ago
and search now for the dark path
I might one day upend the whole of it
and rid the world of all that came
before
well as that Rouse thy interest
[Music]
I see a choice well made thou art a rare
sword
not many would have accepted the offer
but I require as much of those under my
command I anticipate good work from me
then I ask we proceed with haste there
is in my service I
Warrior by the name of Blythe I would
have thee join him in searching for the
hidden treasure of nutron the Eternal
City I have called for Blythe to Greed
thee below take from him
[Music]
hmm
long time friend Blythe
if you've forgotten glad to have you in
the service of mistress Rani well
getting right to business
I'm still in Lim grave the Eternal City
of knockrum Lies summer at the bottom of
this land
I'm planning to go below through the
well in the Mist wood see if I can't
find the road to knock on from there
don't keep me waiting hey
and so you go down deep below the Earth
to an ancient civilization that predates
any others that are found on the surface
here ancestral followers and Clay men
persist well outside the purview of the
earth tree
but built amidst these ancient ruins is
a newer still ancient city nokron
and Eternal City where people of the
night were banished to long ago for
their treason
but their legacy lives on in EG Blythe
Ronnie and now you
[Music]
ah
good to see you apologies mate
but I don't have much to report I can
see bloody knocker on right above me
but I'm absolutely stumped I've tried
all the gateways
to no avail perhaps it's time to ask
celibus
and recall that spiteful little rat
acting like he knew something
give him a squeeze show him just how
sharp my teeth are
I just
I wouldn't go that far besides
I should check on something sure leave
this place to me
you just do what you feel is right
if either of us learns anything
we tell the other
right
and so you go to confront salivus
salivus was once a preceptor a teacher
of magic who served the carrion Royals
when Radigan married Ronaldo these
preceptors were ordered to Don masks of
confidence mouths stitched shut with
gold thread to make it clear that all
their matters were to be kept strictly
private because Radigan was hiding a
secret
that secret was that of course Radigan
was also America
to selivas also has many secrets of his
own
you must be Ronnie's new hiring yes yes
I've heard all about you
I don't know what it is the mistress
sees in a provincial tarnished like you
but since we have The Misfortune of
serving the same lady
I am salavis
preceptor in the Sorceress Arts
as loathsome as syllabus is it seems he
knows something about nokron
well well you're asking me about that
are you the task was left to you and the
mongrel was it not not only are you
incompetent but Shameless to boot well
there's no help in it now there's got a
time as any I'll let you in on it
there's a glintstone so sorry by the
name of Salem in Lim grave
she owes me for the help I gave her when
she was expelled from the Academy I
asked her to look into the Mata some
time ago I'll write you a letter of
introduction
go ask her
so he doesn't know how to get to
knockron but he does know someone who
might
Selen was expelled from Raya lucaria for
her Research into the Primeval current
and among other things these dark arts
taught Selen how to slice open her heart
and imbue a primal glintstone with her
soul
is still in hiding but you eventually
track her down
or what's left of her anyway
[Music]
oh
tarnished are you
I am Jaren
foolish old Warrior and Witness
you didn't no seven did you
well whatever the case
dead now
it is strange though the woman she was
like a husk a soul already fled I
suspect Selen lives on elsewhere I'm
sure she'll turn up eventually in
another body
the night jiren once served the carrion
Royals as a War Commander for their
General radar naturally then he was also
familiar with the carrion Royal
blacksmith
EG
well I haven't heard that name in an age
then you must serve princess Ronnie the
next time you speak to EG
tell him this the Festival of radon will
surely set Ronnie's fate back into
motion
by the bye
is that old fool still hammering out
weapons
his enormous frame cramped in that
little place bit of a haughty sort
strange fella when I knew him and funny
thing his swords were all planted Stone
but not one of them decayed when faced
with a Scarlet rocked
gerund shares a long history with his
General radon the man preferred a
nomadic existence and yet before long he
became sworn to redone Bound by an oath
of honorable death so jiren was there
when radon conquered the stars and he
remained by his side even after the
Scarlet rot brought the general to his
knees for he had an oath to keep
a promise to bring radon an honorable
death even if it meant releasing the
night sky from his grasp
Geron
now that's a name I haven't heard for a
while
Uno
wait how did I not see it before
I ought to retire as War counselor for
such a gross oversight let me explain
the fate of the Guardian royal family is
Guided by the stars as is the fate of
Lady Rani
first air in the Korean Royal Line the
general gradan is the Conqueror of the
stars who stood up to the swirling
constellations halting their movement in
a smashing Victory and so if General
radon were defeated the Stars would once
again resume their movement as would
lady irani's destiny
so although he has lost his mind to rot
Rodan still somehow keeps the stars and
Ronnie's fate in stasis this is why you
need him dead
hmm
so rani's faith is kept in stasis by
stars goes for Dan
I'll be on my way to this Festival of
Rodan
you're coming too right
to redan's festivities I'll meet you at
Red main castle in caled the way ahead
is pleasingly simple
we fight sword and fan
[Music]
ah there you are took your sweet time
the players are all made up I'm waiting
for the curtain let's give them a show
to remember just don't you go dying on
me
for Ronnie's sake too
Champions welcome
the stars of aligned the festival is
nigh
General Rajan mightiest demigod of the
shattering awaits you
Champions
prepare for battle
defeat the general kind glory and grab
that great rune
a celebration of War
the dragon Festival
[Music]
thank you
well played good sir my thanks to you
and your razor sharp wits then there's
nothing left to say except I am Iron
Fist Alex
foreign
we can't really be certain why radon was
holding back the Stars was it to defend
his home
was it on behalf of the golden order or
did he simply have something to prove
whatever the case with his death rani's
fate is immediately freed from stasis
and a falling star tears through the
Earth in lindgrave opening a direct path
for her and you to nochron
ah good
I was waiting for you what a sick way to
fighting the glory of the Clash is
shared
by radon
and you and did you see that afterwards
falling star right before our eyes
I can't fathom was holding back
something of that scale
he was a living legend If Ever I saw one
and the path has now been cleared
tanakra
irani's fate will be decided let's meet
with a falling star bit the Earth we'll
take up our souls once more
for mistress Rani
[Music]
ah
you finally come
Blythe told me everything you've
defeated General radam unlocking the
stars there is no parallel to your
achievement
nor to Lady irani's acute Judgment of
character
thanks to you
lady rami's fate once again stirs
or blinds wanted me to tell you not to
bother waiting for him
and head straight to nochron Blythe as
being given an important task apparently
a matter of great urgency
not a weight Blythe
descend on the ground alone with a
fallen Star Struck limb grave and make
it yours
the precious Treasure of knockrum so
that lady Rani May tread the dark path
of the emperion
and so you scramble through the debris
left by a falling star and finally make
your way towards nocron
this is one of three
Eternal cities to wear a race called the
Knox were banished long ago four somehow
they had invoked the ire of the greater
will and the knocks were forbidden from
returning to its surface
we don't know exactly what they did to
deserve this eternal entombment but it
probably had to do with a weapon The
Treasure of nokron a Finger Slayer blade
born of a corpse and drenched in Blood
and said to be capable of harming the
greater will and its vassals
so it was that the nox became nothing
more than another civilization that had
lost its fate sharing their ruins with
silver tears listless treasure hunters
and the songs of the ancestral followers
this is nokron
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
but now that radon's death has freed the
Fate in the night sky we are able to
discover nochron's treasure this is what
Blyth was sent to find yet we are the
ones to claim it
so that Ronnie can finally Usher in the
stars and bring about her age of night
ah
it was the
even in my Slumber I sensed it it is in
thy possession is it not
the hidden treasure of knockrun
my thanks
finally all the pieces are in place
soon must I begin my journey
upon the dark path only I may tread
but before I leave
I must entrust thee with this
take it
my thanks for thy Sterling efforts
my discarded flesh lieth beyond the seal
and locked by it
a strange gift perhaps
but a rare sort such as thee would
welcome it I'm sure
I want to talk about Ronnie's dark path
she had to do some pretty terrible
things to get here for example she stole
Destin's death and sacrificed her own
corporeal flesh to rid herself of the
hold that the fingers had over her and
to her this was necessary in order to
rid the world of all that came before
and upend the whole of it
foreign
sacrifice wasn't all that was required
for Destin's death demanded a body and a
soul so another demigod was very
carefully selected and she chose Godwin
the golden by killing him Rani could at
once shed her body and strike a terrible
blow to the golden order as well ridding
them of Godwin the golden who was
probably the very best of them
we all know what happens to Godwin so
you have to ask does rani's end justify
the means
I am certain now
fate steered us to our first encounter I
must thank torrent too for his part
[Music]
oh there you are
good of you to drop by have you heard
lady Irani has departed on her journey
along the dark path of the Imperium from
Rena's rise
as she calls it it would not have been
possible without you
as lady irani's War counselor and
moreover her childhood Warden
I express my deepest gratitude
you and only you
were lady rani's true champion
my purpose is nearing its end
I've served lady Irani for as long as I
can remember it has been a long and
wondrous Journey
now lady Irani is in your hands I pray
that you serve her well
until the very end
[Music]
so we decided to take the portal at
Rena's rise this Tower is likely named
after the snowy Chrome the tort Ronnie
her sorcery Rani modeled her doll after
that mentor and Rani and the doll that
she inhabits are busy somewhere on the
other side of this portal
which leads to the angel river which
flows underneath Leonia underneath the
Moonlight Plateau here you find a
miniature doll a tiny replica of Rani
that she likely devised so that she
could Advance unseen in this place for
her two fingers are close and their
baleful Shadows are even closer prowling
looking for trespasses looking
oh a dogged fellow aren't we or is it
merely thy Habit to talk to dolls
fine
I hadn't expected any soul to recognize
me in this guys but now the cat is out
the bag I cannot allow thee thy freedoms
perform for me as Service as recompense
eliminate the baleful Shadows which
prowl these lands the name of Rani the
witch is already sullied by Thee I will
not broke disobedience in this matter
so Rani is here trying to get close to
her fingers so that she can kill them
and finally finish what she started long
ago even without rani's body to
Puppeteer her two fingers still command
great power remember these are the
mouthpieces of the greater will they
conjure great light and so naturally
also have the power to cast living
Shadows the baleful Shadows are one such
example and the Shadows of the Imperium
are another but even the two fingers are
capable of erring in their judgment
let us speak of the past a while
I was once an imperial of the demigods
only I mikola and Melania could claim
that title each of us was chosen by our
own two fingers as a candidate to
succeed Queen America
to become the new god of the coming age
which is when I received Blythe
in the form of a vassal tailored for an
imperial but I would not acquiesce to
the two fingers I stole the Rune of
death
slew mine own imperian flesh casting it
away I would not be controlled by that
thing the two fingers and I have been
cursing each other ever since and the
baleful Shadows
are there assassins
soon you size up against a baleful
shadow which naturally resembles Blythe
it's easy to imagine than why someone
might doubt his loyalty
when I turned my back upon the two
fingers
Blyth remained my loyal Ally
though he was created a vassal full of
Aryan he was a colossal failure on the
part of the two fingers
Blythe and EG both aren't willing to
give too much to me yet they both
understand
what lieth beyond the dark path that I
must betray everything
and read the world of what came before
ah
should I add thee to the list another
one kind of heart
as kind of heart as they
ah
this form hath loosened my tongue I've
let slip too much forget what those
heard
forget
perhaps the baleful Shadows are what the
fingers think Blythe should have been
Red Phantoms without Blythe's great sort
of frost and with blades of destined
death instead the tool that only the
Agents of order have any right to wield
now
[Music]
foreign
the last
tell the two fingers that Ronnie the
witch cometh
drenth thy flesh with a fateful wound
near to heal
beautifully fought my thanks
it was more of a challenge than I
envisioned now I can finally stand
before them this is farewell my dear
help life
and EG I love
that this whole time life couldn't be at
rani's side fighting on her behalf so
you had to be instead
EG LED you to believe that Blythe was
sent away on more important matters but
what could be more important than this
so you return to Leonia and front him on
the matter very well that is something
you should know
the two fingers gave Blythe to Lady Rani
as a faithful follower
a very Shadow
incapable of treachery but if Lady Irani
as an imperian resists being an
instrument of the two fingers the shadow
will go mad
transforming from a follower
into a horrid curse but such is his
Destiny in such matters Blythe's own
thoughts hold no weight it pains me so
but he must be neutralized for lady Iran
is sick
so EG had blive locked away in an Ever
jail in Lim grave incidentally it's the
exact same cell that a supposedly
traitorous Bloodhound once occupied
and now the half wolf is here imprisoned
not for any treachery but to prevent it
oh it's you it's me life holy EG drop me
here
told me I'd bring North but bailed to
Lady Irani but there's no chance that
could happen I'm part of a bee
a very shadow
I thought oh EG knew was much honestly
[Music]
I don't know what's going on anymore
my thanks friend
I'm going to see Mr sarani now
I don't know what came over old EG but
even if they all just Slim
I need to check the mistress is safe no
Ronnie can finally set in motion the
fight against her fate she's dreamed of
for so long
[Music]
as you can see Blythe is still in
control even as the two fingers are
nearing their death at the hands of Rani
yet Blythe remains this living
contradiction forced to be loyal to two
parties who are at complete odds with
one another
EG believes that this should drive him
mad especially this close to the end at
the final stage of rani's ultimate
betrayal but it hasn't
according to carrion tradition the
princess of karia is supposed to give a
ring and sword to her chosen consort but
Rani locked away her ring of betrothal
in the grand library and engraved it
with a warning instead telling you not
to take the ring from this place warning
that the Solitude beyond the night is
better left for her alone
but you ignore her and follow doggedly
in her path
I thought I might expound a little
further
upon the order I Envision mine will be
in order not of gold
stars and moon of the chill night I
would keep them far from the earth
beneath our feet as it is now life and
souls and Order are bound tightly
together
great remove
and have the certainties
emotion faith and touch all become
impossibilities which is why I would
abandon this soil with mine order what's
Thou come to me even now
[Music]
essentially rani's order would be one
that is largely removed from the world
the Goddess that spearheads it would be
unreachable she would not accept the
love of the masses there worship their
offerings none of it this differs
greatly from America's golden order
which demanded veneration it's wiped out
other ideologies it grafted those it
couldn't wipe out unto itself and gave
the world absolute evils to content with
all with America as its figurehead
so to bring about such drastic change
it's no surprise that Rani has to go to
extreme lengths to become her Lord you
have to find your own way to the
Moonlight plateau
past a malformed star ring of betrothal
in hand to a place defended by rani's
oath sworn Dragon the Cathedral of Manus
zealous the word zealous means Heavenly
but the word Manus means of the hand
so you learn that it's here that rani's
own Heavenly hand had settled two
fingers that brazenly lurk underneath
the cathedral named after them two
fingers that no there is no weapon that
could kill them except for the Finger
Slayer Blade the legacy of the Eternal
City of necron which was finally put to
use by Rani herself
[Music]
foreign
so it was thee who would become my Lord
perhaps I
Monday I am pleased however
thou art a fit in choice I go now to the
night sky
it is there I shall find mine order I
bid thee travel the path of the Lord
and once all is done
we shall see each other once more
Ronnie's sigil is a full moon
cold and Laden and this sword is a beam
of its very light gifted by a carrion
Queen upon her spouse to honor long
tradition
so it was you that would become Ronnie's
Lord not Blythe who was forced to wait
while you fulfilled the role of Shadow
and consort
with the two fingers dead something has
indeed broken in life but somehow he
still remains loyal to Rani the law
states that Blythe would have defied
Destiny itself if it would have had him
turn upon his lady
but Ronnie was always destined for the
dark path
since there Falls no shadow where there
shines no sun Rani leaves her Shadow
behind
[Applause]
[Music]
no
I'm part of her very being
I could never betray her
no matter what might happen
[Music]
laughs
[Applause]
[Music]
stop please Riley
she meets me
foreign
[Music]
for so long but in the end only you can
go on
promise to look after blinds for me will
you the man is honest to a fault
unfortunately
fortunate now he has you
[Music]
before Blythe's death he was attacked by
a group of black knives it's impossible
to know who sent them or why they acted
as they did but if they've gone after
blive then it follows that the next
Target would be EG
unthinkable
how could Blythe how did he break free
from his cell no
more importantly lies became a curse
that plagued lady Rani yet even in
Madness gave himself to her I've made a
grave misjudgment
and I thought myself a capable War
counselor I'll catch up with you soon
enough flies when I do
I only hope you'll accept my apology
thank you
as you must
lead Irani along the path
of Darkness
inevitably EG dies fighting as well
destined to catch up with Blythe in
death as you escape the consequences and
continue along the path to Eldon Lord
thank you foreign
[Music]
the Elden ring is set aside completely
to be eclipsed by the moon
as it was long ago back when fate was
still in the night sky
in the age before the archery
before the Elden ring commanded the
Stars
[Music]
the battle is over I see
I do solemnly swear
every living beard and every living soul
now come at the age of the Stars
a Thousand-Year Voyage under the wisdom
of the Moon
here begin it's a chill night that
encompasses all
reaching the great beyond
[Music]
interfere
and loneliness
as the path stretches Into Darkness
so rani's order will still exist but it
will never again be seen believed in or
touched by the living
to bring this about a sacrifice is
absolute she has to leave and never
return
but at least she'll still have you
well then
shall we
my fair console to turn up
thank you for watching you know despite
being one of the most convoluted quest
lines that from software has ever
devised rani's ending is the most
popular ending in Elden ring it speaks
to the power that this narrative has
that so many of you took the time to
have your playthroughs defined by it and
that's why we wanted this prepare to cry
episode to be the best of all so special
thanks then to everyone else who made
this project what it was first and
foremost to miss Pap 1 who was my
project partner my editor and capture
artist he also gave really valuable
Insight on which parts of my script
worked and which didn't and all of this
wouldn't have been what it was without
his help and then there's John Devlin
the artist for prepare to cry's awesome
visual introductions we set out to
create scenes that players were never
able to see in game and I think we
achieved that goal John put a Monumental
amount of effort into this art and I'm
so appreciative of that
and then it was Xavier who brought this
art to life animating it and never
complaining even though I was probably
really annoying whenever I requested a
ton of changes so huge props to Xavier
and then there was Arcane Bard who
worked on the sound effects and music
for this introduction bringing it to a
whole new level where the music and
sound effects could perfectly match the
tone of what's seen on screen that is so
difficult to do but they nailed it
finally Alex Roe contributed the music
for the nocron scene he took a few notes
of music that the ancestral shamans sing
and he turned it into this fully fledged
Masterpiece that was just amazing to
show off in this video but finally thank
you to you guys your views and your
support on patreon or you buying
merchandise all of that just allows me
to justify spending a lot of money
commissioning the most talented people
out there for these projects so thank
you for enabling all of this this marks
the end of the five main episodes of
Elden ring prepare to cry which we
wanted to be really epic in scale
because all of these are based around
some of the most powerful stories each
corresponding to an ending in the game
there are still more prepare to cry
videos that we want to make and there
are definitely more lore videos I want
to make but they'll probably have to
wait until I've spent some good time
with Ahmed core so this is kind of
goodbye to Elden ring content for a
little while but I'll be back don't
worry about that thank you again for
sticking with me through all of this
thank you for watching and I'll see you
next time